Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安（Marianne）。在深入今天的节目之前，我想快速和大家分享一件目前正在发生的激动人心的事情。如果你曾想过如何创造源源不断的被动收入，而不是没完没了地用时间换取金钱，那你一定会喜欢由我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“奔向持续收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是有志成为心理学家、心理健康从业者，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. with Dr. Marianne Trent.
这些原则都同样适用于你。此外，丽莎本人还将亲自送出丰厚的奖品。如果你通过我的专属链接参加挑战，你将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）进行一对一一小时指导的机会。想了解更多信息吗？当然想啦。快去查看我的 Linktree 链接（Dr. Marianne Trent），或者关注我的社交媒体渠道，或者给我发个私信，我会把所有详情告诉你。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。如果你正准备成为一名心理学家，那就让这期节目成为你的向导吧。玛丽安·特伦特博士的节目。
Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. So I love introducing you guys to different areas where you potentially could work or gain experience along your route to wherever your ultimate career goal might be. And today's guest is going to talk with us about something you might not have heard of, as it wasn't something I'd heard of before. We're going to be talking about training in psychoanalysis and so I hope you find it a really useful episode. If you'd like to discuss any of the content in the podcast do come along to the Aspiring Psychologist Community free group on Facebook. I hope you find this useful and I look forward to catching up with you on the other side. Hi welcome to the podcast Eloise Skinner. Hi Eloise. Hi, thank you so much for
你好，欢迎收听《有志心理学家播客》（Aspiring Psychologist podcast）。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。我非常喜欢向大家介绍各种潜在的工作领域，或者在你通往最终职业目标的道路上可以积累经验的方向。今天的嘉宾将和我们讨论一个你可能从未听过的话题，因为这也是我之前没听过的。我们将探讨精神分析的培训，希望这会对你非常有启发。如果你想讨论播客中的任何内容，欢迎加入我们脸书（Facebook）上的“有志心理学家社区”免费群组。希望这期节目对你有所帮助，我期待在节目后半部分与你交流。你好，欢迎来到本期播客，埃洛伊丝·斯金纳（Eloise Skinner）。你好，埃洛伊丝。你好，非常感谢
having me. Oh, you're more than welcome. Thank you for coming on. So we've been thinking a little bit of a little chat before about many things really, about you having changed careers and about what you're doing currently. So we should introduce the fact that you're here currently because we're kind of looking at alternative, you know, methods for working in kind of mental health therapy roles. And that's what you're doing now, isn't it? Do you want to tell us a little bit about what you're doing? Yeah, absolutely. So as you said, I had a bit of a career change over the last few years I started in corporate law so I trained as a lawyer um I went to law school so I studied law at uni and then qualified as a solicitor in the UK and or in England Wales and um and then I practiced law for about five
邀请我。噢，不用谢，非常感谢你能来。我们之前稍微聊过很多事情，比如你的职业转型以及你目前在做的事情。所以我们应该介绍一下你目前从事的工作，因为我们正在探讨从事心理健康治疗角色的替代方法，而这正是你现在在做的事，对吧？你想跟我们简单聊聊你现在在做什么吗？好的，没问题。正如你所说，在过去的几年里，我经历了一次职业转型。我最初是做企业法律的，也就是受训成为一名律师嗯，我读了法学院，在大学里学法律，然后在英国（或英格兰和威尔士）获得了律师资格嗯，接着我当了大约五年律师，
years and during the pandemic I had a bit of a moment where I was like this is the time to make a change because you know everything else was so uncertain. And it seemed like if there's any time to really uproot your life, it might be in the middle of everything that was already happening. So then I decided to take a break, actually. I sort of called it a break to myself so that I would have some ability to maybe come back if I wanted to and yeah in that break I started a business which is really around helping people find a sense of purpose and meaning and also working with like schools and young people around those topics and yes I was also doing my training to become a psychotherapist at the same time so that was the training sort of helped me re-pivot my career
在疫情期间，我突然有了一种想法，觉得是时候做出改变了，因为你知道，其他一切都太不确定了。在一切都充满变故的时候，似乎正是彻底改变生活轨迹的最佳时机。于是我决定休息一段时间，其实我当时对自己说是给自己放个假，这样如果我想回去的话，还留有一点回旋的余地。是的，在那段假期里，我创办了一家公司，主要帮助人们寻找使命感和意义，同时也与学校和年轻人合作开展这些主题的活动。是的，与此同时我还在接受成为心理治疗师的培训，所以这段培训某种程度上帮助我实现了职业重心的转变，
from one to the other it was like a nice bridge between going from one thing and then sort of helped me re-pivot my career from one to the other it was like a nice bridge between going from one thing and then sort of helping me see that there was a different direction in the future. Brilliant thank you so yeah that is some pivot isn't it from from lawyer to psychotherapist um how does the training for for your psychotherapy work? So my training is part-time which means that it's kind of in terms of time commitment it's one or two sort of like big chunks of time per quarter let's say so like it will be three or four days every few months and then those are those were during the pandemic online so a lot of it was just on zoom to begin with and then it started becoming in-person meetings so we're back in person now which is really nice actually and you can imagine like a psychotherapy training is I'm sure yours was as well like really important to be with the rest of
从一个行业转向另一个行业，就像是一座连接过去和未来的桥梁，帮助我看到未来还有不同的发展方向。太棒了，谢谢你。所以，从律师转型为心理治疗师，这确实是一个巨大的转变呢。那么，你的心理治疗师培训是如何进行的呢？我的培训是兼职的，这意味着从时间投入来看，每季度会有大概一到两个比较集中的时间段，比如说每隔几个月会有三四天。在疫情期间，这些培训都是在线进行的，所以一开始很多时候都是在 Zoom 上完成的，后来逐渐转为线下见面。所以我们现在恢复线下上课了，这其实真的很棒。你可以想象，心理治疗的培训——我确信你的经历也是如此——与同组的其他人在一起、去了解他们是非常重要的。所以，是的，我们恢复了线下，每次培训就像是长周末或者四五天的集会，每个模块结束时还有考试。
your group and sort of get to know them so yeah we're back in person and yeah it's like these sort of long weekends slash like four or five day meetings and exams at the end of every module. And the way our training is structured in existential analysis is what they call the basic training, which is sort of an introduction to the topic and like the basic framework of the field. And you get assessed on that and then you move into the clinical side, which is sort how to apply it to different clinical situations and that's where I am at the moment right towards the end so I have um as we speak I have two more modules and then I will be done um but I did the basic training I think finished about last year. Brilliant so you're on on the countdown now yes almost there the end is sort of insight not quite yet but almost I see so I'm going to ask what feels might be a stupid question but my only real
我们接受的生存分析（existential analysis）培训的结构是这样的：首先是所谓的“基础培训”，它相当于对这个主题的介绍以及该领域的基本框架。你会接受这方面的评估，然后进入临床阶段，也就是学习如何将它应用到不同的临床情况中。我目前正处于这个阶段的尾声。也就是说，在我们录音的时候，我还有最后两个模块就完成了。不过我的基础培训大概是在去年左右完成的。太棒了，所以你现在在倒计时了，对吧？是的，快要完成了，终点就在眼前——虽然还没完全结束，但已经快了。明白了。接下来我要问一个听起来可能有点愚蠢的问题，但我对“生存”（existential）这个词唯一的真正理解来自于我的成长经历，当时我们经常看一部叫《恋爱时代》（Dawson's Creek）的电视剧，不知道你有没有看过。
understanding of the term existential comes from my upbringing where we used to watch something called Dawson's Creek I don't know if you've've ever watched it. And it was regarded as sort of an existential naval gazing series. And so that's really my only bolt on to that term, you know. And sometimes I still hear songs, and I think, oh, that would have made a great song for the soundtrack of Dawson's Creek. Like, oh, you know, woe is me.
它被认为是一部充满“生存主义式无病呻吟”（existential navel-gazing）的系列剧。所以，这真的是我将这个词联系起来的唯一依据。而且有时候我听到一些歌，还会想：天哪，这首歌放进《恋爱时代》的原声带里一定绝了，就像那种“天哪，我怎么这么命苦”的感觉。
Could you tell us a little bit more in a more up-to-date accurate reflection not involving Dawson's Creek what existential psychotherapy is Eloise? Yeah I love that that's a great reference um yes so it kind of is about all of those feelings and all of those emotions as well um it's a really broad field actually and it's still very much evolving so it's a field of psychotherapy that um has a lot of different sort of elements within it and a lot of different um ideas and theories within it um and it really stems from well a couple of places there's obviously existentialism as in like the branch of philosophy which um is sort of an inspiration for a lot of the work and theories.
埃洛伊丝，你能用更现代、更准确、不涉及《恋爱时代》的方式，给我们多讲讲什么是生存心理治疗（existential psychotherapy）吗？哈哈，我太喜欢这个比喻了，真是个绝佳的参考。是的，它其实也关乎所有这些感受和情绪。这其实是一个非常广泛的领域，而且仍在不断发展中。它是一个包含许多不同元素、不同理念和理论的心理治疗领域。它主要源于几个地方，其中显然包括作为哲学分支的“存在主义”（existentialism），这为许多工作和理论提供了灵感。
Try to apply that in a more practical setting or like help people through some of those issues. And then one central piece of body of work or essential figure in the field is Viktor Frankl, the author of Man's Search for Meaning, where he kind of sets out logotherapy, which was his way of applying sort of more existential interpretations to psychoanalysis and psychotherapy. And now it can be practiced in many, many different ways. I'm training in something called existential analysis, which is like a more specific part of existential therapy as a whole. But there are obviously lots of lots of other ways to practice it as well and really at the heart of it it's about um well it's about addressing the idea of the whole person and making sure that you're um sort of encompassing the entirety of the person so not just um your mind or your body or you know this kind of spiritual sense or you know the soul
我们要尝试在更实际的场景中应用它，或者帮助人们度过其中一些困境。该领域的另一个核心著作或核心人物是维克多·弗兰克尔（Viktor Frankl），他是《活出意义来》（Man's Search for Meaning）的作者。他在书中阐述了“意义疗法”（logotherapy），这是他将更具存在主义色彩的解释应用到精神分析和心理治疗中的方法。现在，它可以以许多非常不同的方式进行实践。我正在接受的是所谓的“生存分析”培训，这是整个存在主义治疗中更具体的一部分。但显然还有很多其他实践它的方法。归根结底，它的核心在于探讨“完整的人”这一概念，确保你能够包容一个人的全部，
as it was originally referred to but the entirety of the person so taking into account um all of our experiences and our backgrounds and our histories and what we feel and think about things and how we react and sort of working with that as a whole um and then another idea another central idea within the field is having this sense of um yes to life which was actually a title of one of victor frankl's books or a translated title which is the sense of being able to um have the sense of uh personal presence within your own life to be connected to your life to be in dialogue with the the way you live your life and the choices you make and being able to have this fundamental yes to like being here and doing the life that doing the life that you're doing um so those are some ideas but that's the field it's very it's much more much much more than
不仅是你的心灵、身体、这种精神层面的感知（或者最初被称为“灵魂”的概念），而是整个完整的人。它将我们所有的经历、背景、历史、我们的感受和想法、以及我们的反应都纳入考量，并作为一个整体来进行工作。该领域的另一个核心理念是拥有一种“对生命说是”的态度——这其实是维克多·弗兰克尔某本书的书名（或翻译书名）——也就是能够在自己的生活中感受到个人的存在感，与自己的生活建立连接，与自己生活的方式和做出的选择进行对话，并且能够对“能够来到这里并过好当下生活”这件事发出根本性的肯定。这些都是其中的一些理念。当然，这个领域远不止于此。
that of course so sort of the yes philosophy would be like ultimate mindfulness like really choosing to mindfully be where we're at right now yeah absolutely it's um an element of presence I think is really central to it like that um as you just described I think um you know one of the quotes that's often sort of given in terms of this field and this isn't necessarily from anyone in this field I think it's sort of a summary of some of Viktor Frankl's thoughts and interpretations but there's this idea that between like stimulus and response you could have a gap where you then decide what you're going to do or decide your choices or decide your reactions to life that quote's given around quite a lot often attributed to Frankl but it's sort of a summary of what he would have thought about the field um and yeah so it's this
所以，“对生命说是”的哲学就像是终极的正念——真正刻意地去关注我们此时此刻所在的地方？是的，绝对是这样的。我认为其中包含的一种“在场感”（presence）是非常核心的。就像你刚刚描述的那样，你知道，在这个领域经常被引用的一句名言——这不一定出自该领域的某个人，我认为它算是对维克多·弗兰克尔的一些思想和解释的总结——有这样一种观点：在“刺激”和“反应”之间，存在着一个空隙，你可以在这个空隙中决定你要做什么、做出你的选择，或者决定你对生活的反应。这句话经常被引用，通常被归功于弗兰克尔，但它更像是对他关于该领域思想的总结。
idea that you have a sense of autonomy or like personal determination to craft your life in the way that you want you have the ability to choose your responses to the things that happen to you and so it's very much yeah mindfulness I'd say is a good way of describing it and it does um sort of associate itself with a lot of the more like yoga and meditation style choose your life be present in your life you know um be present in your body ideas as well um but just the different interpretation of that I see thank you I was listening to um radio to Jeremy Vine recently and um they were talking about whether it's ethical and whether it should be banned to bring cakes into shared offices. I don't know if you heard the programme.
是的，所以这种观点认为，你对自己的生活拥有自主权或个人决定权，能够按照自己想要的方式塑造生活；你拥有选择如何回应发生在你身上的事情的能力。所以，是的，我认为“正念”是一个很好的描述方式。它确实也与许多瑜伽和冥想风格的理念有很多相通之处，比如“选择你的生活、活在当下、活在你的身体里”等等。只不过它是对这些理念的一种不同诠释。原来如此，谢谢。我最近在听 Jeremy Vine 主持的 BBC Radio 2 节目，他们当时在讨论把蛋糕带到共享办公室里到底道不道德、应不应该被禁止。不知道你有没有听过这个节目。
And the theory was, you know, we've all been there, haven't we? You know, if people bring in cake, you weren't necessarily looking for cake. You weren't necessarily going to have cake that day. But when you see it, you know, you are more likely to eat it or, you know, it's interesting to hear about what you're saying. Actually, you know, you do still have choices. It's not just stimulus and response. There's something in between and you can hold on to your values and what is true to you. Yeah, absolutely. And I think that's a really central idea of the entire philosophy behind this field is that you do have in every situation you have a choice or you know you always have the ability to decide who you are and how you respond to certain things this is kind of the fundamental freedom of the human being of the
他们的理论是，你知道的，我们都有过这种体验。如果有人带了蛋糕来，你本来不一定想吃蛋糕，那天也不一定打算吃蛋糕。但当你看到它时，你知道，你更有可能会去吃它。听到你刚才说的，真的很有意思。实际上，你其实仍然是有选择的。这不仅仅是“刺激”和“反应”，在这两者之间还有别的空间，你可以坚守自己的价值观以及对你来说真实的东西。是的，绝对是的。我认为这也是整个领域背后哲学的一个真正核心理念，那就是在任何情况下，你都有选择权，或者说你始终拥有决定“你是谁”以及“你如何回应某些事情”的能力。这是人类的一种基本自由——决定你将如何在这个世界上前行，或者你将如何对事物做出反应。所以，是的，在那种情况下，你可以看到：“哦，是的，这可能会更有挑战性一些。”但其中存在着一个巨大的空间，你可以在这个空间里决定你要做什么、如何回应。正如你所说，很大一部分内容关乎价值观、你的立场、你对某些特定事情的看法，以及你如何看待自己与生活的位置关系。所以，了解这些基本价值观我认为是为日后做出这种选择奠定基础的一个非常重要的部分。
ability to decide how you're going to move through the world or how you're going to react to things and so yeah in a situation like that you you can see oh yeah it might be a bit more challenging but there's a huge space in which you can decide what you're going to do how you're going to respond and as you said a lot of it is about values and where you stand and what your opinion is about certain things and how you feel about your position to life um so knowing those fundamental values I think is a really important part of sort of laying the foundations to make that choice later on. Great and just thinking about our audience being aspiring psychologists it can be really quite tricky to get into qualified professional psychology routes and it can be really oh really frustrating really just full of dismay along the way sometimes can you give our audience some advice
太棒了。考虑到我们的受众都是有志成为心理学家的人，进入合格的专业心理学路径可能会非常棘手，这一路上往往充满挫折和沮丧。你能从存在主义的角度给我们的受众一些建议吗？告诉他们如何应对这种不确定性，以及如何应对他们目前生活中正在经历的一切？天哪……我想，在这个领域中你可以采用的工具或步骤之一，就是培养生活中的安全感与稳定感，或者试着培养更深层次的安全感。有一个专业术语叫“基本信任”（fundamental trust），这几乎就像是一种信任感，或者说你在世界上感到在场、安全和稳定的感觉。
from an existential perspective about how to cope with that uncertainty and how to cope with yeah whatever's going on for them in their life right now yeah wow um I think maybe one of the tools or one of the um steps that you can take within this field is this idea of safety and security in your own life or trying to cultivate a deeper sense of that. And there's a term that's used called fundamental trust, which is almost like your sense of trust or your sense of being present and safe and secure in the world um and I think that's one of the things that's always helped me through periods of anxiety is this knowledge that you know things change around you things come and go good and bad things happen like stressful things happen and you know the world sort of changes a lot but ultimately if you can cultivate this sense of I guess fundamental trust in your own self and in your presence in the world like you're the sense
我认为这是帮助我度过焦虑期的法宝之一，那就是坚信：你身边的事务会发生变化，人事有代谢，好事坏事都会发生，压力重重的事情也会出现，世界确实在不断变迁；但归根结底，如果你能培养出这种对自我的基本信任感，以及对自己在世界上存在感的信任——也就是觉得自己能够存在、自己属于这里、自己能够占据一席之地、并且在这个世界上有相当扎根的感觉——当你经历生活中的风风雨雨时，这会是一种非常有帮助的自我感知。他们有很多练习来培养这种信任感，比如一些专注于身体的练习会很有帮助。
that you're able to be here that you belong that you're able to take up space and that you're you know fundamentally quite grounded in the world I think that can be a really helpful um sort of perception to have of yourself as you kind of move through your life and there are lots of exercises that they have to cultivate this sense of trust um things like uh sort of body focused exercises can be quite helpful so there's an exercise called the armchair exercise um where the student or the practitioner would sit in a chair with your feet on the floor and then you would sort of go through these steps of um just bringing your awareness to the space bringing your awareness to your body and bringing your awareness to the sense of being like grounded and present and then you can even use phrases like um you know I am secure I'm grounded sort of um
有一个练习叫“扶手椅练习”（armchair exercise），学生或执业者坐在椅子上，双脚着地，然后通过几个步骤将注意力带到空间中、带到身体中、带到那种扎根和在场的感觉中。你甚至可以使用一些短语，比如“我很安全，我很踏实”，这有点像你可以不断默念的咒语式短语。关注你的呼吸，体会那种完全在场、存在于你的身体和生活中的感觉。关于这个练习有几种不同的变体，但我想它的目的真的是为了让人感到安全，并在你的生活中培养出更强的安全感。我认为类似这样的事情，以及其他专注于身体的实践，可以成为通往那种感到非常安全、对世界充满信任的感觉得桥梁。
almost like a mantra type phrase that you can just sort of like run through um focus on your breath um you know in the sense of being like fully present and within your body and within your life um so there are a few variations on that exercise but I guess the the intention of it is to really feel secure and to cultivate like a greater sense of security in in your life I think things like that as well as like other body focus practices can be a real like bridge into that sense of being really secure and trusting in the world yeah and so there's definitely some sort of affirmation work in there as well um which is something i've been finding quite useful lately actually and i love i love that idea of
是的，所以其中绝对包含了一些肯定语（affirmation）的练习。这其实是我最近发现非常有用的一种方法，我太喜欢“允许自己占据空间、占据地方”这种想法了。我想，通常作为女性——我是以女性的身份在发言——这不一定是我们习以为常的。甚至在我们成长过程中，当还是个孩子的时候，大人常会对我们说——哪怕我们希望别人听到我们的想法——往往都是大人们先开口说话，而我们习惯了变得渺小、习惯了没有自己的观点。这可能会很棘手，在董事会里很棘手，在会议室里很棘手，在阶梯教室里也很棘手：“我是谁，我有什么值得说的吗？”所以我很喜欢这种赋能的理念。是的，完全如此。我想，回到那种“置身于自己的生活之中”、“对生活说是”或对生活采取一种积极姿态的感觉得到，你致力于做你想做的事、做出选择、寻找自由，去塑造和设计你自己的生活并对发生在你身上的事情做出回应。
giving yourself permission to take up space take up room um i think often as women specifically i speak as a woman um that's something that we're not necessarily you know and even when we're growing up we're told like you know i want to hear what you've got to say as a child you know and even when we're growing up we're told like you know don't want to hear what you've got to say as a child you know often it's the adults that get to speak first and we just we get used to to being small and not having opinions and that can be tricky it can be tricky in boardrooms it can be tricky in conference rooms it can be tricky in lecture theatres you know who am I to speak what have I got anything worth saying so I like that idea of empowerment yes you have absolutely and I guess coming back to that sense of being within your own life and having this yes to life or this position to life where you're committed to you know doing the things that you want to do making
这些理念都可以贯穿到你刚才谈到的所有那些情境中。它始于这种非常个人的工作：你可能只是坐在椅子上，专注于呼吸和身体。这看起来似乎不是迈出了巨大的一步，但随着时间的推移，这会变成你的立场、你的态度以及你诠释世界的方式。然后，你会将这种状态融入到每一个具体的情境中，这样当你身处阶梯教室，或者在某些情况下为自己发声时，
your choices and finding your freedom um to craft and design your own life and respond to the things that happen to you these are all ideas that kind of feed through into like all of those situations that you were talking about it sort of starts with this really personal work where you might just be sitting in a chair being like focusing on your breath and your body and you know it doesn't seem like a huge step to take but over time that becomes sort of your position your attitude and the way you interpret the world and then you sort of feed that out into every single situation so that when you are in like a lecture hall or when you are you know advocating for yourself in certain situations
那些立场、那些基本的态度就会回馈到你的生活中。有时候，这种转变可能相当难以察觉。如果你是一个正在接受心理治疗的人，你可能会觉得心理治疗有点令人沮丧，因为它并不总是能带来立竿见影的转变。它不像你去健身房，两周后就能多做一个俯卧撑那样立竿见影。但在心理治疗或这些更注重个人的实践中，你很难看到立竿见影的、过夜式的转变。这可能会让人有点沮丧。但是，是的，我想作为长期实践这些内容的人——在接受培训之前，我就曾是生存心理治疗的学生——它确实会在你生活的方方面面产生影响，带来一种非常令人满意和充实的改变。太好了。我刚刚在想我们可能会共事的某些客户、我们看到的某些问题，以及我们可能会遇到的某些诊断。比如创伤后应激障碍（PTSD），这是由于某人身上发生了非常可怕的事情而导致的。这不是他们的选择。但是我们该如何与他们合作，或者如何让他们参与进来，如何与他们共同制定方案，来帮助他们思考自己的立场和选择呢？
those positions those fundamental attitudes sort of feed back into your life um and it can be quite imperceptible I think sometimes psychotherapy can be a bit frustrating if you are you know someone who's undertaking psychotherapy because it's not always an immediate transformation and you can't see like as if you were going to the gym and like in two weeks you can do an extra press-up or whatever but with psychotherapy or these more like sort of personal focus practices, it's hard to see immediate sort of overnight transformations. And that can be a little frustrating. But, yeah, I would say as someone who's been practicing this stuff for a while, as a student of existential psychotherapy before I trained in it, it definitely does. You sort of see it feed through into the rest of your life in a really satisfying and fulfilling way. Great I was just thinking about some of the clients that we might
是的，这是一个非常有趣的例子。因为在生活中，有很多时候我们的自由是受限的——如果我们认为“哦，你拥有选择的自由，你明天醒来可以去跑步，或者你可以环游世界”等等。其实每个人的自由都受到限制，大多数人的自由在非常非常实际的层面受到限制：你可能没有身体能力，或者你没有钱，或者无论如何，你没有那种能够实现所有可能选择的环境。所以，我想当你谈论一种缩小的、受限的自由领域时——在其中你仍然有选择，但它们在不同方面受到了极大的限制，或者也许你无法察觉所有的选择，又或者感觉似乎没有什么选择可供你使用——维克多·弗兰克尔的著作会真正鼓励人们，只去关注那些你仍然拥有自由的地方。显然，他的许多经历都是在纳粹德国集中营的背景下形成的。你知道，在那种情况下，人们确实没有任何自由或自主权。
work with and some of the issues that we see and some of the diagnoses that we might see and with something like PTSD so post-traumatic stress disorder, that has happened as a result of something really awful happening to somebody. That's not their choice. But how do we work with them or kind of get them on board or formulate with them to help them think about their position and their choices? Yeah. And I think it's a really interesting example because there are a lot of times in life where our freedom, if we think, oh, you have freedom of choice, you can wake up tomorrow and go for a run or you can travel the world or whatever. Everyone's freedom is restricted and most people's freedom is restricted in some very, very practical ways. So you don't have the physical ability or you don't have the money or, you know, whatever. You don't have the circumstances that would allow for all of the choices that could be possible um so I guess when you're talking about a narrowed form of a narrowed field of freedom where you do have
但他在观察到的是，人们依然能够开辟出微小的选择空间；或者说，能够选择如何应对发生在你身上的事情，这才是人类真正的自由。这种自由并不是指你可以决定那些实际发生在你身上的事情或迎面而来的遭遇，而是指你以某种特定方式回应它们的能力——你对局势的态度、你将如何处理它。这种自由在任何情况下都依然存在。我想，如果你觉得自己被剥夺了许多现实中的选择，这正是你可以紧紧抓住的东西。而且，存在主义治疗只是与其他疗法配合使用的一种工具而已。所以，当谈到更复杂的临床情况时，其他疗法显然也是很有帮助的。但这种感知是：好的，当我们剥离一切，当你在这个情境中没有其他选择时，你仍然拥有决定自己如何应对这些事情的能力。
choices still but they're drastically restricted in different ways or maybe you can't perceive all the choices or it seems like it feels like there isn't much choice um available I think Victor Frankel's work would really encourage um sort of just focusing in on the places that you do have freedom still. So obviously, a lot of his experience was formulated in the context of the concentration camps in Nazi Germany. And, you know, people didn't really have any freedom or autonomy in those situations um but what he was observing was people were able to carve out little pieces of choice or you know the freedom to choose fundamentally your own responses to the things that happen to you is sort of the freedom of a human being the freedom to decide not the practical things that happen to you or the
是的，好的，所以我们现在就可以做出回应，即使我们在当时无法按照自己选择的方式、或者无法按照我们当时希望的方式去做出回应。没错，就是这样。其中蕴含着一种在当下为自己的选择承担责任的感觉。这里有很多传记类的工作，你需要回首过去，审视那些将你塑造为今天的你的种种经历。正如你所说，即使你觉得过去没有任何选择，你也确实做出了那些将你带到这里的选择，所以你可以将这种承担责任视为你自由的一部分，然后，正如你所说，在当下做出选择。太好了，谢谢。那么，对你和你同期的学员来说，理想的客户是谁呢？是的，他们在生活中可能会经历什么样的
things that come your way but the ability to respond to them in a certain way like your attitude towards the situation how you're going to deal with it that freedom still exists in any situation and I guess that is something to hold on to if you're someone who feels like they've been stripped away of a lot of practical choices and I mean existential therapy is just one tool to be used alongside other things of course so when you're talking about more complex clinical situations definitely other therapies are helpful as well but that perception of okay when we strip it right down what do you have if you don't have any other choices in the situation you still have the ability to decide how you're going to respond to the things that happen.
问题、症状和困难？他们怎么知道自己真正需要的是生存心理治疗呢？这是一个很好的问题，特别是考虑到这种疗法还不是很广为人知。所以我想人们需要花上一段时间才能接触到这个领域，或者找到它、偶然发现它。我想，很显然，有些人——这也许就是我当年的情况——只是在苦苦寻找某种深度，却在自己的生活中感到有点迷失。维克多·弗兰克尔用过一个词叫“存在主义真空”（existential vacuum），指的是当人们陷入这样一种境地：他们看不到意义感和目标感。这确实是我当时的体验——一切都挺好，但没有任何深度，所以你只是四处飘荡，心想：“这一切到底有什么意义？”
Yeah, okay, so we can respond right now, even if we couldn't respond to how we chose, or how we would want to have done at the time. Right, right. And, and there's a sense of sort of taking ownership of your choices in the moment. There's a lot of sort of biography type work where you're looking back at your past and seeing the things that have sort of formed you into who you are today and as you said even if you felt like there wasn't any choice in the past you did make choices that have sort of brought you to where you are so you can take ownership of that as a part of your freedom as well and then as you said making choices at the moment. Great thank you so who would be the ideal client for you and people in your cohort? And yeah, what problems and symptoms and kind of, yeah, difficulties might they be experiencing
当我寻找这类疗法时，我正处于那种状态，而这对我真的非常有帮助。所以人们可能正处于这种状态，无法真正看到更大的意义感或目的感。你也可以在更倾向于危机的情境中使用它，比如意义的急剧丧失、或者某种过渡性事件（如悲伤或职业转型），亦或是身体的生理变化（如疾病或其他对你自由的限制）等等。在这些情况下，你试图夺回生活中的在场感并为自己重新找回它。但事实上，我认为意义疗法（logotherapy），特别是它的理念在于：你不一定非得带着某种具体情况来，你
in their life? How would they know that actually, you know, the thing they needed was existential psychotherapy? Yeah, it's a good question, especially because it's not that well known. So I think it takes a while for people to sort of come to the field or to find it, to stumble across it. I think, obviously, people, maybe this was my situation, who are just really searching for some kind of depth and feeling like a little bit lost in their own lives. There's this phrase that Viktor Frankl uses uses called the existential vacuum which is when people sort of get trapped in this place where they can't see a sense of meaning and purpose which is really my experience of like sort of being you know everything is okay but it doesn't have any depth to it so you're sort of just floating around thinking like what's the
不必带着诸如“我已经离婚了”、“我正经历着这件事”之类的问题来，你不必带着某种亟待解决的事情来。你大可以只是来探索你的生活。因为这里的核心观点是：地球上的每一个人都拥有一种在生活中保持在场并做出选择的感觉。所以，即使你的生活看起来非常顺利，你也可以随时探索这种疗法。不过，它当然也可以用于临床环境中更严重的创伤情况。太好了，谢谢。了解一些背景总是很有用的。如果人们想探索培训，这种培训的普及程度如何？人们该如何接触到它？它是自费的吗？能跟我们讲讲其中的实际操作层面吗？
point in anything and um that was where i was when i sort of sought out these this type of work and this has been really really helpful for me so people may be in that situation where they can't really see a greater sense of meaning or purpose um you can also use it in moments of more like like crisis type situations you know a drastic loss of meaning or a transitional event say like grief or um career change might be one as well or um physical changes to the body like illness or you know other restrictions on your freedom things like that where you're sort of trying to take back the presence in your life and reclaim it for yourself but really I think logotherapy especially the idea is that you don't have to be someone with a situation you don't
当然可以。关于意义疗法（logotherapy），市面上有几种不同的培训项目。比如爱尔兰的维克多·弗兰克尔中心（Victor Frankl Center），我认为它是主要的机构之一。他们提供自主学习的课程，也有更大型的文凭课程。这些课程似乎都是兼职的，我不认为有任何全日制的校园课程。从更具学术背景的角度来看，我想有几所大学开设了生存分析相关的学位课程，你可以在那里进行大学水平的学习。显然，如果你想执业，我想你需要将其转换为执业资格课程，但这可以成为了解这些主题的一个很好的途径。生存分析（existential analysis）的中心实际上在维也纳。所以我的培训是与
have to come with like oh I've been divorced or you know I'm going through this thing or you don't have to come with something that you're working through you can just come and explore your life because I guess the sense is like every single person on the planet has a sense has a sense of being present in their lives and making choices and so you can always explore this work even if your life is like going really great um but yeah it can be used in situations of more um trauma as well in clinical settings as well great thank you um a little bit of context is always useful and in terms of if people wanted to explore training um and you know how widespread is it and how do people access it is it self-funded could you tell us a little bit about the practical elements to it please absolutely so um for logotherapy
维也纳的生存分析中心进行的，不过该中心现在已经扩展到其他地方了。加拿大有很多生存分析的工作。看到它传播到哪里很有意思：加拿大、英国、维也纳，还有俄罗斯等地。在这个主题上有相当多的工作在开展。不过，是的，我的课程是自费的，所以实际上我不太清楚如果你把它当成第二个学位会是什么情况。我对英国教育体系的运作方式了解得不多，从我对英国教育体系的了解来看，老实说，我觉得可能没有多少资助。当我读第一个学位时，我显然申请了学生贷款；而对于这个培训，我原本假设会有某种支持，但我想也许会有点棘手，因为我同时还在兼职工作，所以我心想：好吧，那就试着自己出资吧。
logotherapy there are a few trainings around um there's the victor frankel center in ireland um i think it's one of the main ones and they do courses that are like self-study um and also like a bigger diploma course as well um that I think is all part-time so I don't think any of it is like full-time on campus um and then from a more like academic background I think there are a few universities that do sort of existential analysis like degree type courses where you would actually go and study at a university level obviously then i think you would need to convert it into a practicing um qualifying course if you wanted to practice but that could be like a nice way to learn about the topics um and then existential analysis is really centered in vienna um so i'm training with
这其实挺艰难的。我前几天还跟别人说：“我真不敢相信心理治疗培训竟然这么贵。”这似乎把很多人挡在了这个行业的大门之外，因为你必须支付执业课程的费用，然后还要支付作为见习治疗师的所有实习时长费用，同时你还要应对第一次执业所带来的一切琐事。所以，是的，这确实压力山大。我不知道你的听众里有没有人——我确信你的听众会更清楚这该如何完成，以及你是否需要资金支持。但对我来说，就是一边工作一边硬扛。谢谢，这种挣扎是真实存在的。而且有些专业合格的心理学家分支也必须自费，这真的……感觉极其不道德。
um yeah a center for existential analysis which Analysis, which is centred in Vienna, but has now spread out to other places. Canada has a lot of existential analysis work. It's funny to see where it spreads to, but Canada, the UK, Vienna, and also sort of places like Russia as well. There's quite a lot of work out there in this topic. But yeah, my course is self-fundedfunded so I'm actually not sure what the
你能告诉我们，生存心理治疗师通常会在什么样的环境中工作，或者你在哪里可能会看到或偶遇他们吗？是的，我想很多更偏临床的心理学家，如果他们在其他形式的治疗上有过基础培训，可能会对这些疗法有一些了解。你可能会通过你正在看诊或共事的治疗师接触到它。所以，是的，你可以在临床实践中看到它——在医院、诊所里，或者通过与治疗师进行一对一的咨询。它有时也会被应用在学校里，有一些生存分析专门针对年轻人开展工作，特别是在从学校向成年过渡的那个阶段，这可能会是一个非常艰难、非常具有存在主义色彩的时期，让人开始反思我是谁、我在世界上的位置在哪里。
situation would be if you took it as a second I don't know too much about how the UK I imagine there's not much funding around to be honest from what I know about the UK education system but um when I did my first degree that was obviously then I used student finance and then this I'm assuming there's some kind of support available but I thought maybe it would be a bit too tricky because I'm working as well part-time I thought okay let's just try and fund it myself um and it has been quite difficult actually um and I was saying to someone the other day like I cannot believe how expensive psychotherapy trainings are like it seems to cut a lot of people out of the
《恋爱时代》那种氛围。所以你在思考你想做什么，我真的希望我当年能有一些东西来支持我度过那个阶段的这类工作。但确实如此。在其他地方，比如你刚才说的自由受到一定限制的地方，我想这也是你可能会更多地看到这些疗法出现的地方。比如监狱，或者处理身体自由丧失的医疗情境等类似情况；还有悲伤辅导员（grief counselors），或者你正在经历的各种失落。它也可以用于创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）或其他临床状况，比如人们从创伤情境中回归，甚至像维克多·弗兰克尔那样从集中营回归——也就是在战时或经历非常严重的创伤情境之后，如何重建生活并在此之后寻找自由。
profession because you know you have to pay for like a practicing course and then obviously all of your hours as well as a trainee therapist um and yeah you're practicing uh all of the things that come along with practicing for the first time so yeah it's a lot I don't know whether you're I'm sure your listeners will have a much better sense of like how it can be done and if you need funding but um yeah for me it's just been working alongside and struggling thank you the struggle is real and there's um there's branches of professional qualified psychologists that also have to self-fund as well and it's just like it's just yeah it seems massively unethical um could you tell us what sort of settings existential
太棒了，谢谢。这是一次非常有趣的旋风之旅，带我们领略了我以前绝对没有考虑过的内容，而且能为心理健康实践的其他领域以及广阔世界中正在发生的事情带来一些启示，总是让人感到非常美好。所以非常感谢你。我知道你已经出版了好几本书，而且新书也即将问世，对吧？能跟我们简单聊聊这些书吗？谢谢。是的，我的前几本书更偏向商业导向，是关于法律的。然后当我创业之后，这本即将问世的新书书名叫《但是你还活着吗？》（*But Are You Alive?*），它完全是关于这些理念的。所以它很好地总结了生存分析的一些思想、意义疗法、维克多·弗兰克尔的大量著作、一些实用练习，同时也有一些更侧重身体的实践，比如瑜伽、冥想和正念（正如你刚才所说），并试图将这些与更具精神层面的事物结合起来。作为我寻找意义和目的之旅的一部分，我曾花了一年时间在一个寺院社区接受培训，所以书中包含了很多这方面的实践，并试图将存在主义治疗的一面与寺院修行的一面结合起来，提供一些帮助你在日常生活中活得更有深度的练习。这就是这本书的构想。太棒了！如果能当一次寺院社区里的“墙头草”（旁观者），一定非常有趣，我敢肯定。是的，太棒了。那么，哪里可以
psychotherapists might find themselves working in or where you might where you might see or bump into them yeah i think um a lot of sort of more clinical psychotherapists who have had a basic training in other forms of therapy might have a little bit a sort of um an idea of these therapies so you might be introduced to it there through just a therapist that you're seeing or that you're working with so yes you can um see it alongside or you can see it in clinical practice in hospitals in clinics uh just one-to-one with a therapist and it is used in places like schools sometimes so there's a little bit of existential analysis that works with younger people especially in that transition from sort of
心理治疗师可能会发现自己身处这样的工作环境中，或者你在那里可能会遇到他们。是的，我认为，许多接受过其他形式疗法基础培训的更有经验的临床心理治疗师，可能会对这些疗法有一些了解。所以，你可能会通过你正在咨询或合作的治疗师接触到它。是的，你可以将它与其它疗法结合起来，或者你可以在医院、诊所的临床实践中看到它，甚至只是与治疗师进行一对一的咨询。它有时也被用于学校等地方，因此有一些存在主义分析法适用于年轻人，特别是在从某种类似...
more like school level to adulthood can be a really difficult and very existential time to be reflecting on who you are where you are in the world um dorsal creep kind of vibes um so you're thinking about what you want to do and i think it could be really helpful that I actually wish I would have had something during that period to support me in this kind of work. But yes. And then other places where, like you were saying earlier, sort of where your freedom is restricted a bit. I think that's where you see might see these therapies come in a bit more. So things like prisons or, you know, sort of medical situations where you're dealing with a loss of physical freedom something like that um grief counselors um as well or yeah things like um losses that you're going through um and it can also be used in situations of like ptsd or other clinical
学校阶段过渡到成年阶段的时期，这可能是一个非常困难、非常具有存在主义色彩的时期，让你反思自己是谁、你在世界上的位置——有点那种“背脊发凉”的感觉。所以你会思考你想做什么，我认为这真的很有帮助。其实我希望自己在这个时期能有一些东西来支持我做这种工作。但确实如此。然后是其他地方，就像你刚才说的，你的自由受到了一些限制。我认为这正是你可能会更多看到这些疗法发挥作用的地方。比如监狱，或者你知道的，那种需要应对失去身体自由等情况的医疗情境，或者悲伤辅导员，或者经历失去等情况...
conditions say people are returning from like a traumatic situation or even people returning from well for victor branko's situation like the concentration camp so the idea of wartime or a really traumatic situation and that you're sort of kind of rebuilding your life and finding your freedom after that brilliant thank you it's been a really interesting whistle stop tour through stuff that i certainly hadn't considered and it's always nice to to shed some light on other areas of kind of mental health practice and things that are going on um in the wider world so thank you so much for that and I know that you've got a number of books under your belt and a new one coming out as well haven't you could you tell us a little bit about those thank you yes um so yeah my first couple of
比如人们从创伤性情境中归来，甚至人们从维克托·弗兰克的集中营那样的经历中归来——因此，战争时期或非常具有创伤性的情境的概念，以及你在那之后如何重建生活并寻找自由。太好了，谢谢你。这是一次非常有趣的闪电式参观，了解了我以前肯定没有考虑过的事物，能够照亮心理健康实践以及广阔世界中正在发生的其他领域的某些方面，总是令人愉快的。非常感谢你的分享。我知道你已经出版了好几本书，而且新书也即将问世，对吧？你能给我们简单介绍一下这些书吗？谢谢，是的，所以我的前几本...
books were sort of more like business focused books um in law and then um when I started the business and then this third one that is coming out um is called but are you alive question mark and it's all about it's kind of about these ideas actually so it's a good um little summary of some of the existential analysis ideas logotherapy a lot of Viktor Frankl's work in there, some practical exercises, but also some more sort of body-focused stuff. So some yoga and meditation,
书更偏向于商业导向，主要涉及法律领域，然后当我开始创业时……接下来这本即将出版的第三本书书名叫《但是你还活着吗？问号》，它主要就是关于这些理念的。实际上，它是对一些存在主义分析理念、意义疗法以及维克托·弗兰克的大量著作的一个很好的小结，里面包含一些实用的练习，但也涵盖了一些更侧重于身体层面的内容。所以比如一些瑜伽和冥想，
mindfulness, as you were saying earlier, and trying to bring that together with some more spiritual things as well. So as part of my sort of journey to meaning and purpose, I did spend a year training with a monastic community so it's a lot of those practices and trying to sort of bring together the um existential therapy side and also the monastic side and sort of practices to help you live deeper in everyday life that's the idea amazing fly on the wall in the monastic community would be interesting I'm sure yeah yeah hopefully brilliant where can
正念，就像你刚才所说的那样，并试图将这些与一些更具精神性的事物结合起来。因此，作为我寻找意义与目的之旅的一部分，我确实花了一年的时间在一个修道院社群里接受培训。所以书中包含了许多那样的修行实践，并试图将存在主义治疗的一面与修道院的一面结合起来，通过各种实践来帮助你在日常生活中活得更有深度，这就是这本书的主意。太棒了，如果能像修道院里的苍蝇一样旁观那种生活一定很有趣，我确信是的，希望如此。太棒了，请问在哪里可以
people learn more about you or get hold of your books if they want to yeah most things are on my website so if you put my name into google it's just eloiseskinner.com and you should find my website and social media as well um on instagram I'm at eloisealelexia um and yeah that's kind of mostly where i'm at great we'll obviously um have your details in the show notes as well um thank you so much for your time and helping us learn a little bit more about this really interesting area eloise oh thank you so much for having me and i really enjoyed talking to you. Thank you. So there we go. My existential knowledge of Dawson's Creek, who knew that would come in useful one day. Thank you so much to our guest, Eloise. It was a pleasure to speak with her and very much looking forward to reading her new book, which sounds fascinating when that's available and what I will do is when
人们如果想多了解你或者买你的书，该去哪里找你呢？是的，大部分内容都在我的网站上。如果你在谷歌上搜我的名字，网址就是 eloiseskinner.com，你应该能找到我的网站和社交媒体。嗯，在 Instagram 上我是 eloisealelexia，基本上我就是在这几个地方活动。太好了，我们当然也会把你的联系方式放在节目简介里。非常感谢你抽出时间，帮助我们更多地了解这个非常有趣的领域，埃洛伊斯。哦，非常感谢邀请我，我真的很享受和你们交谈。谢谢。好了，这就是全部内容。我对《恋爱时代》的生存主义知识，谁能想到有一天这会派上用场呢。非常感谢我们的嘉宾埃洛伊斯。很高兴能与她交谈，非常期待阅读她的新书，听起来非常迷人，等书上市后，我要做的是
the book is released I will redistribute this podcast episode as well so that we can drum up some more support for her and her work she sounds like a very busy person who's very good at achieving things so hope you found that useful if you want any additional support or guidance to help you in your career as an aspiring psychologist do consider coming along and joining us in the aspiring psychologist membership if you've got any ideas for future podcast episodes do just get in contact with me come and connect and follow with me on socials where I am dr marianne trent everywhere if you're watching on youtube please do take a moment to like the video and comment.
等这本书发布时，我也会重新发布这期播客节目，以便我们能为她和她的工作争取到更多支持。听起来她是一个非常忙碌且非常擅长成就一番事业的人。希望你觉得这期节目对你有用。如果你需要任何额外的支持或指导来帮助你实现成为心理学家的职业愿望，请考虑加入我们的“有志心理学家会员计划”。如果你对未来的播客节目有任何想法，请随时与我联系，并在社交媒体上关注我，我在各平台的用户名都是 dr marianne trent。如果你正在 YouTube 上观看，请花一点时间点赞并留言。
And of course, subscribe to the channel. I will look forward to catching up with you very soon. Our next episode of the podcast is available from 6 a.m. on Mondays. Thank you for being part of my world and I will see you very soon. Take care. from so many things that you can try. The Aspiring Psychologist Collective. The Aspiring Psychologist Collective.
当然，也请订阅这个频道。我期待很快与大家见面。我们的下一期播客节目将于周一上午 6 点上线。感谢你成为我世界的一部分，我们很快就会见面。保重。有这么多事情可以尝试。“有志心理学家集体”。“有志心理学家集体”。
If you're looking to become a psychologist Then let this be your guide With this podcast at your side You'll be on your way to being qualified It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast With Dr. Marianne Turris. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the
如果你想成为一名心理学家，那么就让这成为你的指南。有这个播客在你身边，你将离获得资格不远了。这就是《有志心理学家播客》，主持人是玛丽安·特里斯博士。我叫亚娜，我是一名见习心理健康从业者。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现里面关于所有
different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家，真的非常有趣。它让我惊叹于通往这一目标的途径竟然有这么多，而且没有完美的方式来成为一名心理学家，这让我充满了信心，认为我并没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐你读这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦你开始读，你就放不下这本书了。这期节目暂时还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。